[موسيقى]
بطلب من البحرين وتاييد من الامارات
تجاهلت جامعه الدول العربيه طلبا تقدمت به
السلطه الفلسطينيه لعقد اجتماع طارئ بشان
الاتفاق الاماراتي مع اسرائيل وفقا لما
كشفته مراسلات رسميه من مصادر دبلوماسيه
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه الذي كان
قال العام الماضي ان كل ما يرفضه الجانب
الفلسطيني او العربي هو امر مرفوض من
الجامعه العربيه لم يرى في هذا الاتفاق ما
يستدعي اجتماعا عاجلا لمجلس الجامعه واثر
انتظار الاجتماع الوزاري الدوري الاسبوع
المقبل كما انه لم يرى من موجب على الاقل
لبيان حول هذا الاتفاق
فما الذي ستخرج به الجامعه بخصوص الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي في اجتماع التاسع من
سبتمبر ايلول وهل انتهى دورها في اي تعاط
جاد مع الازمات المتلاحقه في المنطقه اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من
[موسيقى]
سيناريوهات
السلام عليكم ازمات وصراعات وحروب عصفت
ولا تزال بالكثير من البلدان العربيه لم
يكن للجامعه العربيه فيها حضور فاعل او
مؤثر ولم يتجاوز تفاعلها مع هذه الازمات
في افضل الاحوال حدود المراقبه والم بعت
او اصدار بيانات للشجي او
الاستنكار حتى هذا الاستنكار لم يعد ممكنا
الان فقد تكلس الجامعه وعجزت عن التعامل
مع المتغيرات الجديده في منطقتنا خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالتطورات الخطيره الاخيره في
القضيه الفلسطينيه يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه من تونس الدكتور عبد اللطيف
عبيد الامين العام المساعد السابق لجامعه
الدول العربيه ورئيس مركز الجامعه في تونس
سابقا من رام الله الدت الكتور علي
الجرباوي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت ومن بغداد وائل عبد اللطيف الوزير
والنائب العراقي
السابق بعد ساعات من وصول طائره اسرائيليه
الى مطار ابو ظبي قادمه من تل ابيب وعابه
الاجواء السعوديه اصدرت الامارات مرسوما
بالغاء القانون الاتحادي بشان مقاطعه
اسرائيل والعقوبات المترتبه عليه ما يفتح
الطريقه امام علاقات تجاريه طبيعيه متغير
جديد من جمله متغيرات كثيره
لم تستفز جامعه الدول العربيه التي دعت
قبل نحو عام الى ضروره تفعيل المقاطعه
الاقتصاديه لاسرائيل كشكل من اشكال التصدي
للاحتلال وانهائه وانقاذ لحل الدولتين
وعمليه السلام فكيف ستتعامل الجامعه مع
هذه التطورات وتداعياتها على القضيه
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه اسئله صعبه تواجه الج العربيه
الحريصه على اظهار موقفها كحاضنة
لمبادره السلام العربيه التي طرحتها
السعوديه في قمه بيروت عام
2002 بالنسبه لمسؤولين في رام الله فان
الاتفاق الثلاثيه الاماراتيه الامريكي
الاسرائيلي يضعف الموقف الفلسطيني ويسعى
لفرض صفقه القرن التي رفضتها الجامعه
العربيه ومما يعزز تلك المخاوف ان اقدام
الامارات على التطبيع اقترن بالغائها فورا
قانون مقاطعه اسرائيل المعمول به عربيا
منذ عقود اتساقا مع قرارات الجامعه
العربيه ومواثيق لكن الاكثر ريبه واثاره
ان الخطوه لم تواجه اي رفض او شجب من دول
عربيه رئيسيه فمصر ادتها والسعوديه لم
تتطرق اليها بل استجابت سريعا لطلب
اماراتي يسمح لكافه الرحلات من والى
الامارات بعبور اجوائها ما يعني السماح
للرحلات الجويه بين ابو ظبي وتلي ابيب من
التحليق فوق السعوديه
انه تناغم مريب يوحي بان خطوه الامارات
تلك قد لا تعكس موقفها هي فحسب بقدر ما
تؤشر ربما الى موقف محور كامل متكامل
يستعجل التطبيع والشراكه مع اسرائيل ونقله
من السر الى العلد وما ابو ظبي بالتالي
الا بالون الاختبار بانتظار ان تتهيا
السياقات اكثر وها هنا قد لا يكون صمت
الجامعه العربيه بمعزل عن تلك الترتيبات
بما ان النفوذ السياسي والمالي لذلك
المحور عليها دفعها في غير ما مر الى
المسارعه لعقد اجتماعات طاريه من اجل
قضايا ومستجدات اقل اهميه بكثير من ملف
الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي دكتور ع عبد اللطيف عبيد اهلا
وسهلا بك نريد ان نفهم في بدايه هذه
الحلقه اليه العمل في جامعه الدول
العربيه
البحرين قدمت بعد ان قدمت السلطه
الفلسطينيه طلبا لاجتماع عاجل
وطارئ مملكه البحرين ارسلت لجماعه الدول
العربيه رساله تقول فيها لا داعي لهذا
الاجتماع الطارئ فلنترك الاجتماع الدوري
في
التاسع من سبتمبر لنجله لان الموعد الاخر
قريب بعد هذا الخطاب
للبحرين دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
ترسل رساله تثني فيها على هذا المقترح
وايضا تؤيد التاجيل هل من اليات التعامل
في جمعه الدول العربيه ان تنسف دول طلب
لدوله عضو
اخرى
نعم السلام عليكم وتحيه الى الجميع يجب ان
ان نميز في جمعه الدول العربيه بين
الامانه العامه التي هي جهاز تنفيذي محدود
الصلاحيات وبين مجلس الجامعه المتمثل
في الرؤساء والملوك وامراء الدول في هذا
المستوى الاعلى والمستوى الذي تحته هو
وزراء اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه والمستوى
الثالث هو اجتماع المندوبين السلطه
الحقيقيه هي لدى مجلس الجامعه الممثل خاصه
بالملوك والرؤساء
والامراء الامانه العامه هي تتقبل وتسجل
ولا تستطيع ان تفرض شيئا وفي هذه الحاله
فان الدول اي الاعضاء هي صاحبه النفوذ
الكامل ويجوز لها ان ترفض مثل هذا المقترح
الذي تقدمت به دوله فلسطين هذا على الصعيد
الاجرائي البحث اما من الناحيه
ا المبدئيه والاخلاقيه والسياسيه ان شئنا
فان كل شؤون الامه العربيه جديره بان تبحث
على مستوى الجامعه وعلى مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه كما هو الحال بالنسبه للاجتماع
يوم 9 القادم ولكن مع الاسف لا اظن ان
مجلس الجامعه سيتطرق بالكامل لهذا الموضوع
ولا اظن انه سيعطي الفرصه لبعض الدول
الاعضاء في جميعه الدول العربيه للتعبير
عن رفضها لهذه الخطوه التي قامت بها
الامارات نعم وتاكيدا لكلامك دكتور عبيد ا
بالطبع ال السلطه الفلسطينيه طلبت قمه
عاجله لبحث هذا الموضوع تحديدا ايضا دوله
البحرين اعترضت على ان يكون هذا بندا
مستقلا قالت اذا بحثنا هذا الموضوع لا
نريد ان نبحثه كبند مستقل بمعنى الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي نريد ان نبحثه تحت
البند العادي القضيه الفلسطينيه التي نخوض
فيها دائما مره اخرى دوله الامارات تثني
على هذا المقترح وتقول بانها ستتقدم
بمذكره وبمشى قرار تحت بند القضيه
الفلسطينيه البند الدائم التقليدي هذا
ايضا مساله وارده في في العرف عرف العمل
العربي المشترك داخل
الجامعه نعم نعم يمكن ان تدرج يدرج الطلب
الفلسطيني ضمن البند العام الذي هو تقليدي
في كل الاجتماعات وهو القضيه الفلسطينيه
او الصراع
العربي الاسرائيلي ف جدول الاعمال يضبط
بالتشاور وبالاتفاق بين كل الدول ولا
تستطيع دوله ما ان تفرض رايها في جدول
الاعمال وان تكون لها الكلمه الحاسمه اذا
ف لا تنسوا ان هذه الجامعه هي جامعه الدول
العربيه واذا الدول هي التي تقرر وفي هذه
الحاله اظن ان
قرار او طلب البحرين بان يكون الحديث في
موضوع التطبيع ضمن بند عام هو القضيه
الفلسطينيه هو الذي سيتم نعم هذا من
الناحيه الاجرائيه ولكن من الناحيه
السياسيه دكتور علي الجرباوي كيف تتوقع ان
يكون تعاطي جامعه الدول العربيه مع ما
طالبت به السلطه الفلسطينيه في اجتماعها
المقبل في التاسع من سبتمبر
يعني في في ثلاث مستويات المستوى الاول هو
التمنيات والمستوى الثاني هو الينبغي
والمستوى الثالث هو الواقع واذا ما تحدثنا
عن الواقع فالجامعه العربيه لا تملك اراده
خاصه بها الاراده هي
للدول الاعضاء
فيها الماده ثمانيه من الميثاق بتقول
تحترم كل دوله نظام الحكم القائم في دول
للجامعه الاخرى
واسياده وال الاستقلال هو للدول لذلك ما
في عننا اراده للجامعه العربيه نفسها
والتعاطي الجاد اللي انت ذكرته في المقدمه
يعني هذا ينبع ان كان هناك تضامن عربي ان
كان هناك تضامن عربي ما بين هذه الدول
الجامعه العربيه تقوم بما يجب اما ان لم
يكن كما هو الحال حاليا ف الجامعه العربيه
تصبح مشلوله تماما ولا تستطيع ان تقوم
بشيء لذلك ما يجري حاليا من عدم وجود اي
تحرك من قبل الجامعه العربيه يدل على
ان هو مؤشر للوضع العربي البائس و يعني هو
النتيجه لهذا الوضع وليس هو السبب في هذا
الوضع اذا ما تغير وضع التضامن العربي
الجامعه العربيه تكون بخير ولكن ان لم يكن
هناك تضامن عربي ونحن نعرف الان ان انه
ليس هناك تضامن عربي على
الاطلاق الحدود الدنيا حتى اقل من الحدود
الدنيا معنى ذلك ان الجامعه العربيه لن
تكون فعاله لل الان ولا يعني في الاجتماع
القادم ولا بعد ذلك
وا هذه يعني القضايا الاساسيه
التي تصاب بشلل هي القضايا القوميه قضيه
فلسطين هي قضيه المفروض ان تكون قضيه
عربيه قوميه بامتياز وهي التي ستعاني
اكثر
القضايا من هذا الشلل العربي ومن عدم
التضامن ما بين الدول العربيه ولكن دكتور
جرباوي واضح الاستياء الفلسطيني يعني مثلا
الدكتور صائب عريقات دع الامين العام رغم
ان نعلم ان جامعه جامعه الدول العربيه هي
جامعه لهذه الدول في النهايه ليس لها قرار
خاص خاص بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه مثل ما
اشار ايضا الدكتور عبيد ولكن مع ذلك
الدكتور صائب عريقات دعا الامين العام ابو
الغيت قال له اما ان تصدر بيان او تستقيل
بعدما حصل الاتفاق الاماراتي الاسرائيلي
مثل هذه الدعوات الفلسطينيه كيف تنظر
اليها انظر اليها من باب التمنيات من باب
يعني التوقع نحن نتوقع من الجامعه العربيه
طبعا هناك قضيه فلسطينيه قضيه قوميه ونحن
شعب تح الاحتلال يعني نناضل
ضد هذا الاحتلال ونتوقع الدعم من الاشقاء
العرب ولكن يعني عندما لا نحصل على هذا
الدعم عندما يضرب ويطعن هذا الدعم طبعا
يعني هناك توقع من ان تقوم هذه الجامعه
بما يجب عليها بما يجب بما ينبغي عليها ان
تقوم به نحن يعني في تمنيات في ينبغي
ينبغي على الجامعه العربيه ان تقوم بذلك
ولكن نحن يعني انا استاذ علوم سياسيه انا
بعرف شو
معنى ان يكون هناك منظمه اقليميه لا تملك
اراده ارادتها تاتي من الدول ويعني الله
غالب مثل ما يقال في انه الدول لا تريد او
بعض هذه الدول النافذه لا تريد لذلك
الجامعه العربيه المطلوب منها لا تستطيع
ان تحققه وهذا شيء طبعا مؤسف هذا شيء مؤسف
جدا ان يصل بنا الحال الى ما وصل اليه
الان من وضع تردي كامل
تظهره الجامعه العربيه في تلكؤ في عدم
يعني عملها اي شيء وانا لا اتوقع انها
ستقوم باي شيء في الاجتماع القادم لذلك
بالنسبه الي انا شخصيا وبالنسبه للعديد من
الفلسطينيين الجامعه العربيه دورها انتهى
في هذا الموضوع يعني نعم بين الاجراءات
وبين التمنيات والواقع السيد وائل عبد
اللطيف القاضي وائل عبد اللطيف كيف يمكن ل
الراي العام العربي بتقديرك والعراق معني
بكل ما يجري في المنطقه كيف يمكن ان ان
ينظر لهذه الحاله التي وصل اليها العرب
الى درجه انهم لم يعودوا قادرين حتى بالحد
الادنى يعني عاده كانت تعير الجامعه
العربيه بانها فقط تدين وتشجب لكن واضح
الان حتى الادانه والشجب اصبحت سقفا عاليا
الان كيف يمكن ان ان ينظر الى هذا
الواقع شكرا جزيلا تحيه لحضرتك والى ضيفك
الكريمين لعلي اضع ثلاث مراحل
لعلاقه الدول العربيه
ا اللي مرت بها من 72 عام الى حد الان
اقصد
1948 النكسه التي زحفت بها طلائع القوات
العراقيه ومعاها اخوانها من الدول
العربيه من 48 الى تقريبا ال 73 اغلب
الدول العربيه هي
مقاتله ولا تريد على الاقل في العراق ان
نتلفظ بلفظ اسرائيل وانما الكيان
الصهيوني بعد ال 73 حقيقه وما مر بالمصر
الشقيقه تحولنا الى ثلاثه م
الاول هو كامب ديفيد والتسويه السياسيه
او السلم او وبعدها الهدنه والمرحله
الحاليه هي مرحله
التطبيع طبعا لا توجد مرحله في تاريخ
الدول العربيه اضعف
واوه ما تمر به الدول العربيه
الان وجامعه الدول
العربيه اطلاقا لا يوجد لها راي في ما
يجري في الدول العربيه لاحظوا مثلا ما
يجري في العراق وفي سوريا وفي لبنان وفي
ليبيا وفي تونس وفي مصر وفي
اليمن شيء غريب يحصل في هذه الدول امام
سكوت مطبق لجامعه الدول العربيه ولا نزال
نعتقد ونؤمن بان فلسطين قضيتنا المر زيه
على الاقل احنا كشعب هسه رغم ان حكومتنا
لم تشجب ولم تؤيد الاتفاق الحاصل الاخير
بين دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده وبين
الكيان الصهيوني لكننا كشعب ومن خلال
القوى السياسيه والوضع الشعبي ندين هذه
التصرفات ونعتقد
ونبقى اصحاب عقيده فيما يتعلق ان الكيان
الصهيوني غاصب وعليه ان يعيد الارض المختص
الى اهلها بحل الدولتين او حلول اخرى على
الاقل
تلائم العداله في في هذا الوضع نعم طالما
انت من العراق حضره القاضي استاذ الاعلام
في جامعه القدس الدكتور احمد عوض قال
كلاما يعني فيه اشاره للعراق يقول دور
الجامعه العربيه انتهى كمنظمه اقليميه
تحمي اعضائها وذلك منذ الغزو العراقي
الغزو الامريكي للعراق عام 2003 تتفق مع
وجهه النظر
هذه اكيد تمام لم يكن لها رايا وكانني عند
قراءتي الى ميثاق جامعه الدول العربيه
ومواده العش ان الجامعه ابتعدت كثيرا عن
ميثاقها وبالاخص الوثيقتين الاخريين اللي
تتعلق بالدفاع المشترك لا دور لها
وبالجانب الاقتصادي ايضا لا دور لها وما
وجدت دورا لجامعه الدول العربيه ليش لانه
الماده خامسه والسيد الامين العام الاسبق
يمكن
يسمعوني الماده
خامسه تقرر انه اذا كل مجلس الجامعه
العربيه بالاجماع يصبح القرار ملزم ولكن
بالاكثر بالكيف اللي يريد يطبقها او ما
يريد يطبقها ولم نحصل في يمكن في اوقات
كثيره على الراي بالاجماع من الصعوبه جدا
ان ان ان تحصل على رايا بالاجماع ولهذا
اعتقد ان الجامعه العربيه اصبحت تابعه الى
الدول المموله الدول المساعده الدول التي
تستطيع انقاذ جامعه الدول العربيه من من
النواحي الماديه او ما الى ذلك من الامور
نعم وابتدا وضعها مع العراق زحف الى سوريا
زحف الى لبنان زحف الى ليبيا زحف الى تونس
الى الجزائر الى اليمن ولا دور لها دورها
ضعيف جدا في العالم العربي نعم اشرت الى
الدول المموله هناك كثير من الاراء دكتور
عبيد تعتقد بان الجامعه الان اسيره
المرحله الخليجيه او العهد الخليجي اساسا
السعوديه الامارات البحرين ومعهما مصر هذا
الرباعي تقريبا هو الذي يتحكم في قرار
الجامعه العربيه في الاول وفي الاخير هناك
نقطه مهمه جدا دكتور عبيد موضوع المقاطعه
المقاطعه كانت دائما والقضيه الفلسطينيه
العمود الفقري ل العمل العربي المشترك
الان المقاطعه انهت دوله الامارات اي
ويبدو ان غيرها في الطريق ايضا مرور
الطائرات الاماراتيه الى اسرائيل منها
واليها عبر الاجواء السعوديه ايضا يعتبر
ضمن ضرب المقاطعه والمقاطعه لها مكتب عربي
و ونشاط ضمن جمعه الدول العربيه كيف تتوقع
التعاطي مع موضوع المقاطعه في الفتره
المقبله ان كان سينظر فيها الاجتماع
المقبل
ايضا
ا لا لا اعرف ان كان الاجتماع المقبل
سيتعرض لموضوع
المقاطعه لكن اعتقد ان دولا عربيه عديده
ستواصل المقاطعه لان المقاطعه مبنيه على
مبدا موجود في ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه وهو ان اسرائيل دوله غاصبه وهذا
مبدا مووجود وتعرضت له كل القمم العربيه
ويتمسك به العرب في كل قمام بدون استثناء
وميثاق جامعه الدول العربيه يقول انه لا
يجوز لاي دوله عربيه ان تتخذ سياسه خارجيه
ذاره بدوله عربيه اخرى عضو في جامعه الدول
العربيه وفي بالنسبه الينا وفي هذه وفي
هذه الحال ف ان التعامل مع الكيان
الصهيوني الغاصب هو ذار بفلسطين وبالشعب
الفلسطيني وبالتالي فان ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه يقر هذه المقاطعه
ويعتبر سندا لهذه المقاطعه واعتقد انه ما
زالت هنالك دول عربيه ستواصل مقاطعتها
لاسرائيل رغم ان نفوذها او ان تاثيرها قد
لا يكون في قوه دول اخرى فقلتم انها تمول
الامانه العامه لجامعه الدول العربيه ولها
سياسه جديده قد يكون فيها وجهه نظر جديده
تتعلق بالتطبيع لاسباب تخص هذه الدول لكن
المجتمع العربي والامه العربيه والمجتمع
والشعب العربي بتمامه وكماله سيواصل
مقاطعه اسرائيل لان الامه العربيه بقطع
النظر عن حكومتها مقتنعه
بان الصهاينه قد احتلوا ارض فلسطين وبان
ارض فلسطين هي ارض عربيه وبان الشعب
الفلسطيني شعب عربي شقيق يجب ان نقف معه
وهذا ما تعرفه اسرائيل ويعرفه الغرب ولذلك
يسعى الى اختراق الامه العربيه ثقافيا
واعلاميا ودبلوماسيا و ح الذي ستربح
اسرائيل من التطبيع مع الامارات قد لا
يكون من الناحيه الاقتصاديه ذا قيمه كبيره
ولكنه من الناحيه الثقافيه والاعلاميه
والسياسيه له وزن وله اهميه بالنسبه الى
اسرائيل علينا نحن ان نذكر شبابنا واجيال
الجديده
و شعب وامتنا العربيه بان اسرائيل تحتل
ارضنا وبانه من واجبنا ان نقف مع الشعب
الفلسطيني وهذه اكبر مقاطعه نعم مشروع
القرار الذي اقترحته السلطه الفلسطينيه
الكتور علي الجرباوي انت اشرت قبل قليل
الى الامنيات
والواقع ال مشروع القرار الحقيقه عندما
تنظر اليه مشروع جدا واقعي يعني السلطه
الفلسطينيه في كل البنود التي تقترحها
عندما تريد بحث موضوع الاتفاق الاماراتي
الاسرائيلي كبند منفصل وليس ضمن القضيه
الفلسطينيه لان التطور ليس يعني
بهذا التفاهه حتى ينظر اليه ضمن مواد اخرى
القرار يقول التاكيد على ان الاعلان
الثلاثي الاماراتي الاسرائيلي الامريكي
ليس من شانه الانتقاص من الاجماع العربي
ليس من شانه تغيير الرؤيه العربيه ليس من
شانه تغيير القرار العربي ليس من شانه
المساس بحقوق الدوله الفلسطينيه يعني
الصيغه جدا واقعيه حتى انه لا يدين ولا
يستنكر وانما يصيغها بهذا الشكل ويقول رفض
ما تضمنه الاعلان الثلاثي وليس لا لا
ادانه ولا شجب ولا كذا ويقول يدعو جميع
الدول الى الالتزام يعني حتى مشروع القرار
الفلسطيني بهذه الواقعيه تعتقد انه لن يمر
ولن يبحث كقرار
مستقل طبعا لن
يمر ذا ان بحث يعني ايضا انا لا اعتقد
بانه سيمر على الاطلاق والموضوع هو لانه
هناك دول عربيه لا تريد ذلك يعني ليس فقط
الامارات ولكن هناك دول اخرى لا تريد ان
يقال لها بانه يجب ان تلتزم ويجب ان
وال الخطه السلام العربيه هي هي الاساس
وكل هذه الامور هي لا تريد ذلك يعني احنا
لازم نشوف الواقع كما هو طبعا يعني ممكن
ندينه ممكن نقول انه مش صحيح ولكن هذا هو
الواقع الان
ان اقليم مفكك اقليم مفكك يتكون من دول كل
دوله ترى مصالحها بعينها فقط وقد يكون
هناك بعض الدول التي ترى مصالحها منسجمه
مع بعضها البعض ولكن ليس اكثر من ذلك
الدول لا تريد ان يقال لها لا يجب ان
تفعلي كذا او ان تلتزمي بكذا ولذلك جاء
الطلب ليس من الامارات وانما جاء من دوله
اخرى ليقال ليقول الجامعه العربيه وقفوا
ما ما تعملوا ولا اي شيء لذلك يعني احن
بنحكي عن كمان اسبوع في اجتماع وسنرى وانا
من الان اتوقع بانه لن يكون هناك قرار لن
يبحث القرار الفلسطيني لن يؤيد القرار
الفلسطيني لان واقع العالم العربي الحالي
هو واقع يعني منهار تماما وهناك من يريد
ان يستظل ب علاقه مع اسرائيل ليرضي
الولايات
المتحده وهناك مصالح صغيره
اه لكل دوله تريد ان ترضى عنها الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه
وان تقوم بعمل ما لها ولذلك البوابه الان
هي من خلال هذا التطبيع يعني قد يكون هناك
دول قد يكون هناك دول يعني ليست ليست يعني
مهروله للتطبيع ولكن هي تذهب الى هذا
التطبيع او ستذهب الى هذا التطبيع لان لها
مارب اخرى مع الاداره الامريكيه لذلك من
من الان فصاعدا سنرى ان هناك دولا عربيه
ان كان بالسر وهو حاصل منذ زمن وان كان
ستظهر للعلن هي خطوه خطوه تذهب باتجاه هذا
التطبيع الان القضيه الفلسطينيه متضرره
نعم متضرره وبشكل كبير جدا يا ريت انه
كانوا قالوا لاسرائيل انه نحن مستعدين ما
اصلا هي ال ال خطه السلام العربيه هي شو
هي تطبيع كامل ولكن مقابل شيء الان
التطبيع لم يعد مقابل شيء للقضيه
الفلسطينيه نعم هو هو هناك وجهه نظر قاضي
وائل عبد اللطيف تقول انه في النهايه في
النهايه من حق اي دوله ان تاخذ القرار
السيادي الذي يلائمه وهناك البعض يبرر
الامارات من هذه الزاويه هي حره ولكن هذا
يترتب عليه اشياء من ذلك مثلا الدكتور
صائب عريقات يقول الامارات لا يمكن لها ان
تلغي وهنا استشهدت بصائب عريقات اكثر من
مره هو من اكثر المسؤولين الف الفلسطينيين
التصريحات في هذا الموضوع يقول الامارات
لا يمكن لها ان تلغي قرارات القمم العربيه
الا الا اذا قررت الانسحاب من جامعه الدول
العربيه اذا طلعت هي حره تفعل ما تشاء هل
هل تعتقد بان هذا هو المنطق المقبل من
اراد ان يفعل شيء فل يفعله هو حر ولكن لم
تعد الجامعه العربيه هي المظله التي يجب
ان يبقى
تحتها يعني حالات الضعف بصراحه واضحه
في جامعه الدول العربيه
وبالاخص بعد 2003 بعد الغزو الكويتي غزو
الامريكي
للعراق هذا الموقف جعل تمزق ونخر في كل
اغلب الانظمه العربيه الان القتال هو مو
عربي صهيوني القتال الان هو عربي عربي وقد
يستعين بالاجنبي على العربي وهذ اول مره
تعيشها المنطقه
العربيه احنا دخلنا مع الغزو
2003 وجامعه الدول العربيه تتفرج ما عندها
اي قرار في هذا الموضوع انتقل القتال الى
سوريا وبدعم من بعض الدول العربيه ولا
موقف لجامعه الدول العربيه ما يحصل في
لبنان ما يحصل في ليبيا ما يحصل في اليمن
ما حصل في تونس ما حصل في الجزائر ما حصل
في مصر هذه المؤشرات بصراحه تعطي انطباع
ان جامعه الدول العربيه قد تراجعت كثيرا
عن
ميثاقها عن ميثاقها وعن المعاهدين اللي
مرتبطات بها اللي هي الدفاع المشترك
والوضع الاقتصادي يعني في الوقت الذي دوله
الامارات العربيه تذهب لتنج الوضع
الاقتصادي مع الكيان الصهيوني في عدها
وثيقه هي للتعامل الاقتصادي مع اشقائها
وشقيقاتها الدول العربيه يعني لماذا
الذهاب الى الكيان الصهيوني وهي ليست دوله
مواجهه تؤثر عليها اسرائيل بشيء او باخر
وانما دوله بعيده لو كانت من الدول
القريبه او المحاد ممكن ان يكون هناك راي
ولكن هي بعيده والدول الاقتصاديه العربيه
كثيره وممكن تنميه الاقتصاد مها ايضا بوضع
افضل من الكيان الصهيوني نعم فاذا حاله
الضعف في اداره جامعه الدول العربيه واضحه
جدا فاما ان تكون فعلا جامعه واما ان تكون
مفرقه للدول العربيه ولهذا تاكيدا لكلامك
سيد عبد اللطيف معضله جامعه الدول العربيه
تبقى اعمق واكبر من مساله انعقاد اجتماع
طارئ او تاجيله فتاريخ حافل بالمواقع التي
لم تتجاوز الشجب والتنديد باستثناء ومضات
نادره في سجل العمل العربي المشترك
الجامعه العربيه بين الفعل المحدود او
المفقود والدور المنشود مع فتحي
[موسيقى]
اسماعيل رغم المتغيرات الهائله والتباينات
بين اعضائها احتفظت جامعه الدول العربيه
طله 75 عاما من عمرها بالقدره على
الاستمرار
كمظلة والفاعليه حتى اصبح احيانا عنوانا
لازمه العرب
وهوانهم لقد كان واقع الجامعه العربيه
دائما من واقع دولها الاعضاء تقوى بقوتها
وتضعف بضعفها لا بل ان سياستها ارتبطت في
معظم المرا راحل بسياسه هذه المجموعه من
الدول او تلك
واستاذته المقر بالنصيب الاوفر من تلك
الهيمنه باستثناء الفتره التي عاقب خلالها
العرب القاهره على معاهده كامب ديفيد
ونقلوا مقر الجامعه الى تونس بين عامي
79 و90 ارتهان جامعه الدول العربيه
لسياسات مصر اختلف باختلاف النظام الحاكم
في القاهره اذ بينما اراد نظام عبد ناصر
الجامعه رافعه لمشروعه السياسي وسندا له
في مواجهته مع اسرائيل والغرب سعت انظمه
ما بعد كامب ديفيد الى جعل الجامعه
العربيه منبرا لتزكيه مواقف القاهره حتى
اعتبرها البعض قسما تابعا للخارجيه
المصريه لا سما مع استئثار مصر بمنصب
الامين العام الذي اعتاد اخر وزير لخارجها
ان يتوج به مشواره السياسي في سجلها
المثقل بكثير من الف ف شل وقليل من
الانجازات تمكنت الجامعه العربيه تاريخيا
من احتواء بعض الخلافات الحدوديه مؤقتا
بين اعضائها كما نجحت في تطويق ما عرف
بازمه ايلول الاسود عام 70 بين الفدائيين
الفلسطينيين والجيش الاردني لكن الجامعه
اخفقت لاحقا في وقف الحرب الاهليه
اللبنانيه عام 75 ومنع اجتياح العراق
للكويت عام 90 ثم الغزو الامريكي للعراق
في 2003
على ان غياب روح التكامل وتغليب المصالح
القطريه كان ايضا من اسباب تراجع دور
الجامعه العربيه حيث اصبح التنسيق الثنائي
او بين مجموعه من اعضائها بديلا عن العمل
العربي المشترك اكثر من ذلك اثرت بعض
الدول التعاون الاقليمي والدولي عن مظله
الجامعه وهياكلها وهي اختيارات تعكس فقدان
الثقه في هذا الكيان بقدر ما تؤكد قصوره
عن مواكبه التحولات في المنطقه والعالم
وعجزه عن التكيف مع المستجدات والى ذلك
القصور يعزى ايضا تصاعد الخلافات العربيه
العربيه حتى داخل الكتله الاكثر تماسكا
وهي مجلس التعاون الخارجي ناهيك عن تعطل
اتحاد المغرب العربي قبل ذلك واذ يضاف هذا
التدهور الى تدويل كل الازمات العربيه
تقريبا بمستويات متفاوته من فلسطين الى
سوريا وليبيا اليمن والعراق والصومال بما
يعني انتفاء اي دور فعلي للجامعه العربيه
فلا اقل الان لانقاذها من اصلاحات جذريه
عاجله تمنحها الادوات اللازمه للفعل
والتاثير والا ظل بيت العرب مجرد فضاء
للاجتماعات والبيانات وحتى تصفيه
الحسابات دكتور عبد اللطيف عبيد عمرو موسى
الامين العام السابق لجماعه الدول العربيه
يقول انا اقتبس هنا يقول في كل الاحوال
ادعو جامعه الدول العربيه الى ترتيب
اجتماع عربي لمناقشه جاده لهذه التطورات
التي بحثنا منذ بدايه الحلقه واعاده تاكيد
قواعد الاشتباك في المساله الفلسطينيه هل
هذا ممكن ا انا اعتبر ان هذا ممكن ودور
ال المثقفين
الجامعيين والاكاديميين والاعلاميين
والفنانين مهم جدا في هذا المجال اي يجب
ان تكون هنالك سحوه عربيه وان تكون هنالك
دعوه
ل تدارس القضايا العربيه
الرئيسيه وفي مقدمتها القضيه الفلسطينيه
وكيف يجب ان نتعامل معها العرب مازالوا
والشعوب العربيه بالاساس مازالت تت ططلع
الى الوحده وقبل الوحده نريد ان نتكامل
وقبل ان نتكامل نريد ان نتضامن وان نتعاون
هذه كلها اهداف
وطموحات وحلم بالنسبه الى الامه العربيه
من المحيط الى الخليج وعلى المثقفين
والاعلاميين والفنانين
والسياسيين ان تتظافر جهودهم من اجل ان
نطرح قضايانا بصوره ديمقراط وبصوره عليه
وبصوره اخويه
والامل مازال موجود في ان نبقى متضامنين
على الاقل مع فلسطين ومع القضيه
الفلسطينيه لان هذا الكيان الصهيوني الذي
زرع يعني في الارض
العربيه هو سبب رئيسي من اسباب تشتتنا
وفرقتنا وتعطل تنميتنا في اعتقادي ان
جميعه الدول العربيه رغم كل الاخفاقات فقد
تمكنت من بعض الانجازات المهمه جدا علينا
انلا ننسى ان جامعه الدول العربيه لم تهتم
بالملفات السياسيه فقط ولكنها اهتمت
بالملفات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والثقافيه بمختلف انواعها واسست منظمات
عربيه قطعيه بعضها قام بانجازات مهمه جدا
مثل المنظمه العربيه التنميه الصناعيه
والمنظمه العربيه للتنميه الزراعيه
والمنظمه العربيه للتنميه الثقافه والعلوم
واتحاد اذاعات الدول العربيه الى غير ذلك
هنالك انجازات كبيره قد لا تكون في مستوى
ما نتح اليه وما تتطلع اليه الامه العربيه
ولكنها انجازات على كل حال تدل على اننا
راغبون في العمق في ان ننجز شيئا مشتركا
واننا لا نزال متعلقين بالوحده العربيه او
على الاقل قلب التكامل العربي الذي يحقق
لنا التنميه ويحقق لنا الامن القومي نحن
لنا مطلبان رئيسيان الامن القومي والتنميه
والجامعه العربيه نستطيع ان نقول انها
قامت ببعض الانجازات علينا ان لا نفرط
فيها وعلينا ان نبني عليها ولكن علينا ان
نعيد النظر في ميثاق الجامعه العربيه لانه
لم يتغير تقريبا منذ تاسيس الجامعه سنه
خمم بعيد وعلينا ان نفعل شيئا مثل الاتحاد
الافريقي على الاقل ان ي خص ان الجامعه
العربيه هي هي اقدم الجامعه العربيه هي
اقدم من من الامم المتحده بسنتين وهذه
مساله يعني مهمه على عكس على عكس هذه
النبره التفاؤل دكتور عبيد هناك نظره
تشاؤميه انقلها ل الدكتور علي الجرباوي
عبد الله بشاره الامين العام السابق لمجلس
التعاون الخليجي كتب في القبس الكويتيه
يقول الاتفاق يعني يقصد الاتفاق الاماراتي
الاسرائيلي سيؤدي الى هنا يبدا كلامه
سيؤدي الى انكماش في اداء جامعه الدول
العربيه مع اعطاء الاولويات للملفات
الوطنيه
ويتلاشى تتلاشى الامكانيات لتوافق عربي
مستقبلي هل هذا ما
ينتظرنا بالتاكيد يعني الحديث عن انكماش
وكانه الانكماش لم يحصل بعد الانكماش حاصل
منذ فتره طويله الجامعه العربيه في
ميثاقها منذ منذ ان يعني تكونت وهي غير
مؤهله غير مؤهله للوصول الى الوحده
العربيه انطوني ايدن في البرلمان في في
مجلس العموم البريطاني عندما القى خطابه
بشان انشاء منظمه عربيه قال بانه ينظر ان
بريطانيا تنظر بعين عطف ل انشاء مثل هذه
المنظمه لانه انا باعتقادي انها هذه
المنظمه هي التي ستحول دون الوصول
الى الوحده
العربيه الجامعه العربيه في وضعها الحالي
في وضعها الماضي حتى الان لم تستطع ان
تقوم بشيء الا اذا وصلنا الى اتفاق ما بين
الدول
العربيه لا يوجد الزام على الاطلاق لاي
دوله عربيه للقبول باي قرار من هذه
الجامعه لذلك يعني على مسيرتنا
الطويله لم نشهد اي حاله من الحالات اللي
كان فيها الزام من الجامعه العربيه لاي
دوله عربيه وانما بالتراضي هذه منظمه
اقليميه اساسها القبول قبول الاطراف اللي
ما بده مش رايح ينفذ والان وصلنا لوضع انه
كثير ما بدهم يعني في في السابق كان في
بجوز حدا اثنين اللي ما بده اليوم صاروا
الكل بدش هي هي المشكله المشكله يعني في
نهايه المطاف ليس في الجامعه العربيه
المشكله في الوضع العربي اللي بتنتج عنه
فاعليه هذه الجامعه اللي كانت دائما
فاعليتها قليله والان اصبحت معدومه تماما
واللي بده يتمه يتوقع من الجامعه العربيه
اكثر من واقعها لن يحقق شيئا نعم في في
اغلب الكتابات التي كتبت قاضي وائل عبد
اللطيف حول اخر التطورات هناك جمله ترددت
في اكثر من مقال يقول بان الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي هو المسمار الاخير
في نعش جامعه الدول العربيه الجمله مريره
ولكن هل تراها
واقعيه بقراءه معمقه للماده واحد من
الميثاق ان جامعه الدول العربيه تنظم
الامور السياسيه بين الدول العربيه وهذا
الموقف الذي اتخذته الامارات هو موقف
سياسي اذا ما مار عن طريق جامعه الدول
العربيه ويجب ان لا نذهب الى هذا الانكفاء
الى هذه المرحله يجب ان نعود الى الحكماء
من الا هم الذين اسسوا جامعه الدول
العربيه في 22 اذار
واسسها الحكماء الذين كانوا يتوقون الى
جامعه تضم كل الصرح العربي وينشدون في ذلك
الوقت بلاد العرب اوطاني من الشام البغدان
ومن مصر الى يمن
فتطوان هذا النشيد لم اراه يعني يقرا هذا
اليوم ولا مع الطلبه ولا مع
وكان العروبه اصبحت متخاصمه بعضها ازاء
البعض الاخر الجامعه العربيه اسسها
الحكماء عام
1945 وفرط بها
الحكماء الزعماء الحاليين فلا بد من
العوده وصوت الحكمه يعود الى ان نعود الى
جامعتنا للدول العربيه وهي متكامله في
الوضع الاقتصادي والجوازات والعمله والامن
وما الى ذلك من الامور منظمات غيرها
لحقتها بعد سنوات طويله كالاتحاد الاوروبي
مثلا وشفنا صارت الفيزا
وعملوا العمله مالتهم
وال توحدوا واحنا امه عندنا لغه مشتركه
عندنا مصالح مشتركه عندنا جغرافيا مشتركه
عندنا لسان ناطق عربي كثير من الامور
توحدنا ولكن الزعماء الحاليين يمزقون جسد
هذه الامه التاريخ ما راح يذكركم بخير
التاريخ سوف يلعنكم والشعوب ايضا سوف تلعن
ان لم تعقدوا جلسات لتفادي الوضع الخطير
لمت اليه الامور بين بلدان الدول العربيه
القوميه شكرا جزيلا لك القاضي وائل عبد
اللطيف الوزير والنائب العراقي السابق من
بغداد شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من رام الله
الدكتور علي الجرباوي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت وللضيف من تونس
الدكتور عبد اللطيف عبيد الامين العام
المساعد السابق لجامعه الدول العربيه
ورئيس مركز الجامعه في تونس سابقا الان
ننتقل الى بعض التغريدات حول موضوع هذه
الحلقه ونبدا بهذه التغريده لاستاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه القاهره الدكتور حسن
نافعه يقول فيها كانت زياره السادات للقدس
خروج على اجماع عربي يحرم التعامل المنفرد
مع اسرائيل وقرار الامارات بالتطبيع اليوم
خروج على اجماع عربي يحرم التطبيع قبل
قيام الدوله الفلسطينيه لو ان الامارات
استوعبت ما جرى للعرب بعد زياره السدات
لما اقدمت على ما هي مقبله عليه فمتى
نستوعب دروس التاريخ الكاتب والمعارض
السوري مح الدين اللاذقاني قال مقاطعه
اسرائيل قانون عربي شامل تلتزم به الدول
الاعضء في الجامعه العربيه والسؤال لابي
الغي امينها الحالي هل سيتم طرد الدول
التي الغت او ستلغي العمل بذلك
القانون اما عبد العزيز التويجري المدير
العام السابق للايسيسكو وهي المنظمه
الاسلاميه للتربيه والثقافه والعلوم فيقول
في عام
1945 اعلنت جامعه الدول العربيه مقاطعه
رسميه للبضائع للبضائع اليهوديه واعتبرتها
غير مرغوب من فيها داخل الدول العربيه
وطالبت كل المؤسسات والمنظمات والتجار
والافراد العرب برفض التعامل بالبضاعه
الصهيونيه او توزيعها او استهلاكها هذا
القرار تجاوزته دول عربيه طبعت واليوم هو
شبه ميت وفي تغريده اخرى اضاف الدكتور عبد
العزيز التويجري من المؤسف محلال عمل
المنظمات الاقليميه العربيه والاسلاميه في
وقت الحاجه الماسه لها نقطتان يسميه ما
يسمي هذه المنظمات منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي جامعه الدول العربيه
اتحاد دول المغرب العربي واخيرا مجلس
التعاون الخليجي هذا الوضع الجامد يزيد
الضعف ضعفا ويهدر جهودا واموالا كثيره
انفقت خلال العقود
الماضيه بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه التي طرحنا
فيها الاجتماع المقبل لجماعه الدول
العربيه التاسع من سبتمبر ايلول المقبل
وما يمكن ان يخرج عنه في
ضوء الجدال الدائر حاليا حول الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي كالعاده نذكركم
ك عاده في نهايه كل حلقه بضروره الانتباه
مجددا ومجددا وباستمرار
للعنايه بالصحه ولعنا بكل الاحتياطات
اللازمه في سياق حرصنا على ان نظل في امان
وفي عافيه من هذا الوباء العالمي وباء
فيروس كورونا حفظكم الله والسلام عليكم
ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله ست